are you 30 yet i'm 32. okay you're 32.
when you were
16 you didn't have that philosophy no of
course not okay when you were 21 you
probably didn't have that philosophy
definitely i know guys that are 21
they're broken [ __ ] they're college
because they don't have this philosophy
and if they think like that they haven't
done anything yet you're saying you're
providing value when you were in law
enforcement
did you have that perspective or is that
perspective just starting and then my
final part to that is
all right when you were starting fresh
and fit
you know and you were just dude we're
just we're starting to pot two years ago
right how long ago yeah so we had like
meaning the the
did this
conviction
happen once
fame and cred kind of came meaning like
where were you at 21 25 versus 30 and 32
if you would break that down you want me
to go from yeah yeah you go no and then
there you go oh well i mean you know at
21 obviously i was you know oblivious to
a lot of the these you know realities
between men and women you know and as i
got older and older and got gained more
experience i was able to figure out um
and i didn't really start like really
figuring this stuff out until my late
20s early 30s um and then we started i i
resigned from the government in december
2020 um and then we started the podcast
uh we filmed our first episode october
26 2020. so we've been on what 14 15
months now a year and a half so you know
and we've been able to enjoy a lot of
success and when you started the podcast
bro yeah did you have this exact same
mindset or was it just kind of the
infancy stage of this mindset like the
polygamous mindset almost it was it was
uh
i believe it but not to this level of uh
okay i i i understood it and i and i
accepted it i just didn't understand it
to this level because i you know i do a
lot of because i'm using your words bro
you said once you reach some value and
you become first you know a king a queen
not a queen but a king a rock star
whatever then all right like there's
it's no doubt that drake is banging all
types of women like that just happens
yeah so this this
i'm just saying successful guys hugh
hefner you know george clooney leonardo
dicaprio it is what it is we've covered
we've covered leo um
but it you know some some goofball 22
year old who hasn't had a job yet it's
like yeah i just are a bunch of women
it's like good luck out there in the
marketplace buddy i would say so it does
you're saying that it comes with
value
fame
money credibility status and these types
of yeah opinions kind of begin to
manifest how does that work i would say
i was i was um
i guess how do i say this i was acting
upon my beliefs probably around 28.
because i i knew it but then i was
finally able to start actually like
enacting on it being monog uh being
polygamous all this other stuff once i
hit around twenty eight and when did it
start for you
okay and how old are you i'm 29 right
now okay yeah so
i do believe the similar um
uh do you fully agree with myron do you
agree with him
i do but i also have a caveat yeah
that's here i believe that i can find
one woman eventually and settle down
with her now that might not be known
right now it could be in the future but
having that uh option to know okay you
know what i'm making a choice where i
can put aside the women that i want to
just mess around with and find one woman
i could possibly do that but maybe in
the future though
[Music]